a piece of astrophysics history was made
right here scientists in Hanover were
the first to get a look at the signal
from measurements made in the u.s. that
directly showed gravitational waves it
was an absolute sensation I'm here to
meet someone who's been looking for
those waves for decades Institute
Director costs and dance man how did he
experience the historic moment it's
right here Institute oh sure I was here
at the Institute and word got around
pretty quickly about we weren't blown
away at first because we didn't believe
it Jonesy it took a long time for it to
sink in Buster God if I co chua danh
sman uses this Apple to explain how
gravitational waves work Einstein
predicted their existence a century ago
in his theory of general relativity
remember practice is X Billy men let's
conduct a practical experiment the
surface of this pond is a two
dimensional space now i'm going to
create a gravitational wave under Garvey
that wants villeroy after all then Dave
is if you google veggie how the circular
wave moves out from the point of impact
it's the same with gravitational waves
the Apple made an indentation in the
surface and that forced the ripples to
spread out it's the same in space the
indentation in space spreads out sounds
simple it is simple this is where the
equipment for measuring gravitational
waves is developed and tested the
researchers in the US who first measured
the waves use detectors just like this
one only bigger why did it take so long
to confirm the existence of
gravitational waves do you want ed is
ugly the basic idea is simple you detect
gravitational waves by measuring
distortions in space we do that by
measuring the lengths involved but very
very precisely because the magnitude of
the distortion is very small the laser
measuring technology we use
has only become available in the past
few years idea of being Yavin sofa fool
this container houses the core of the
detector apples optic today the device
shines a laser beam into each of two
long tubes at right angles to each other
the beams reach the end are reflected
back and then allowed to interfere the
light beams ought to cancel each other
out but if there's some flickering it
could indicate the passage of a
gravitational wave this is what a
readout of the gravitational wave looked
like the first one to be observed it
doesn't look like much to non-experts
but forecasts and dance man it's a
beautiful proof of the phenomenon that
was predicted by Einstein you can even
hear the waves as an audio signal this
is what the patterns of lines and chirps
revealed to the experts around 1.3
billion light years away from the earth
two black holes were orbiting each other
at a speed of 200,000 kilometers per
second the black holes eventually merged
releasing energy greater than that of
the entire visible universe of oblivion
dieses does the astonishing thing is
that this event the most powerful we've
ever been able to measure took place in
complete darkness teams of researchers
went all out trying to detect traces of
radiation from it they looked in the
visual range radio waves x-rays gamma
rays and microwaves but they found
nothing
in other words no telescope could see
the collision of the black holes but
gravitational waves revealed it and one
day they may tell us even more about the
structure of the universe more than
ninety-nine percent of the universe is
pitch-black say the physicists so
researchers are building even more
sensitive detectors to probe these vast
dark spaces one new project being
developed involves three satellites that
would transmit laser beams to each other
over millions of kilometers in space and
precisely monitor the interference
between them Dawn's Minh says this giant
setup would help us to detect
gravitational waves more easily perhaps
even those generated by the big bang
that created our current universe that
has researchers very excited
so this in via esma inch done it may
tell us about the origins of the
universe human being seen programmed to
search for that about design it's like
the way a lot of people enjoy
researching their family tree there's
also nice they want to know where they
came from look how they got here
mentioned visibility for fun what we're
doing is like researching your family
tree on a cosmic scale back to the Big
Bang unfall showing stuff didn't work
notes azulon the scientists have a long
way to go before they get to that point
but they keep working on the powerful
new space-based detector under
development might possibly be ready for
use by the year twenty twenty eight pm
ke mahabali would all unavailability
uptake on robots the league